president Trump criticizing China's
response on the corona virus outbreak
and now Fox News learning the Trump
administration is considering its
options on how to deal with the World
Health Organization Julie internal
reports on that in Washington DC Jillian
hi Bill so Fox News has learned that the
Trump administration is opening up a new
front in the battle against China here
at the World Health Organization we've
learned the US has circulated a draft
proposal to get Taiwan what's called
observer status it's a Power Move that's
intended to punish the organization
quote for being to China centric now
last night at Fox News's Town Hall
President Trump said he's gearing up to
make a decision real soon about whether
to continually funding the w-h-o at all
take a listen the World Health
Organization has been a disaster
everything they said was wrong and their
China centric all they do is a good they
agree with China whatever General wants
to do now the State Department has even
launched a campaign tweet for Taiwan to
gin up support writing the world needs
Taiwan in this fight
tell at w-h-o it's time for Taiwan to be
heard now the State Department and US
officials at the United Nations are
considering a whole range of options to
hold the w-h-o accountable for aiding
and abetting China including the
creation of a whole brand-new global
health body that would have more US
influence take a listen
China behaved like authoritarian regimes
do attempted to conceal and hide and
confuse it employed the World Health
Organization as a tool to do the same
these are the kind of things that have
now presented this enormous crisis an
enormous loss of life and tremendous
economic cost all across the globe the
WH Rose director-general is pushing back
against the u.s. daily critiquing
America's response to the pandemic
without naming names
take a listen the Kobe 19 crisis has
illustrated that even the most
sophisticated health systems have
struggled to cope with a pandemic
national security sources tell Fox News
that China doesn't want Taiwan to have a
seat at the w-h-o because they don't
consider Taiwan an independent country
but meanwhile the Trump administration
is forging ahead with their plan they've
already got backing from Australia
they're now seeking support bill from
France the UK and Germany felt Gillian
Turner thank you for